[Música]
la tormenta invernal eliot comenzó a
debilitarse sin embargo miles de
personas siguen en alerta por intensas
nevadas en Estados Unidos unos 260.000
usuarios tuvieron que pasar Navidad a
oscuras al menos 30 personas han perdido
la vida tenemos ampliación en unos
minutos
Armenia ha calificado la situación como
una crisis humanitaria debido al cierre
por parte de activistas de azerbaiyán
del único corredor que une la región de
nagorno caravaca con el mundo exterior
miles de personas se han manifestado
allí en esta región y piden la apertura
inmediata de la ruta
de acuerdo con el diario bloomberg y de
financial Times indican que unos 250
millones de personas están contagiadas
en China con el Coby 19 el Ministerio de
sanidad chino Indicó que dejará de
publicar estadísticas mientras que los
hospitales están al borde del colapso
muy buenas noches Bienvenidos a las
noticias de Francia 24 soy Santiago
López González Gracias por estar con
nosotros
vamos a comenzar haciendo una
actualización en torno a la tormenta
Elliot en Estados Unidos el fenómeno ya
ha comenzado a debilitarse pero se
mantiene en alerta buena parte del país
debido a Las bajas temperaturas más
bajas de lo normal que se están
registrando en algunos puntos 190.000
personas permanecen bajo alerta por las
Nevadas 260.000 personas pasaron la
Navidad completamente oscuras y cerca de
2.800 vuelos fueron cancelados ya se
habla de al menos 20 muertos en
diferentes estados de todo el país vamos
a conversar sobre este tema con Alberto
Hernández él es meteorólogo lo saludamos
en la Ciudad de México señor Hernández
gracias por estar con nosotros en France
24 y esta tormenta ha sido un evento
extraordinario le pregunto Entonces qué
factores fueron los que se sumaron para
que se formara este tipo de tormenta
inusual Que prácticamente ha abarcado
toda la región de los Estados Unidos y
parte de Canadá y México
Así es gusto saludarte y bueno sí
tenemos una inusual y si bien es época
del año el invierno en el hemisferio
norte pero al haber entrado un sistema
de alta presión a los cinco kilómetros
de altura en el Polo Norte a la altura
entre Canadá y el norte de Alaska este
sistema de alta presión lo que generó es
lo que le llamamos un botice polar con
el signo negativo esto lo que provoca es
de que el Chepo la que normalmente queda
Atrapado más hacia latitudes
precisamente entre Europa y Canadá pues
había bajado en forma de una fuerte
ondulación hacia lo que es todo
Norteamérica ya desde inicios de la
semana pasada estaba monitoreando que
entre Alaska y Canadá se iba
desarrollando este sistema de alta
presión
bastante inusual es lo que le llamamos
un Expreso de Alaska o Expreso de
Siberia porque viene avanzando
precisamente desde desde lo que es este
Asia cubre todo lo que es el Polo Norte
viajó por Japón Corea y después
se comenzó a preparar hacia lo que es
Alaska y Canadá y en estos momentos
después de este prolongado sistema de
onda
gélidado la tormenta invernal de Dios
pues ya tenemos temperaturas que están
disminuyendo a 50 bajo cero en
centígrados 50 grados centígrados bajo
cero señor Hernández
señor Hernández el invierno boreal en el
hemisferio norte apenas está comenzando
Podemos esperar otro tipo de fenómeno
similar y esto que es relación puede
tener también con la emergencia
climática con el cambio climático que
hemos sido testigos a lo largo de los
últimos años en el planeta
y tiene mucho que ver tiene mucho que
ver porque en la temporada psiquiátrica
que también terminó el 30 de noviembre
vimos trayectorias muy largas de ciclón
que son totalmente
[Música]
tractores que se fueron desde los
trópicos hasta el Polo Norte entonces
tengo una reacción del planeta para
tratar de hacer el equilibrio térmico
Entonces ahora lo que está mandando es
aire frío desde el Polo Norte hasta
latitud tropicales
señor Hernández Muchas gracias por haber
estado aquí en France 24 habernos
explicado este fenómeno climático Muchas
gracias y felices pascuas para usted
allí en México
vamos a cambiar de tema miles de
personas se manifestaron en la ciudad de
este panaker en la ciudad más poblada de
la autoproclamada República de astah en
la región de nagorno caravag todo esto
en contra del bloqueo por parte de
azerbaiyán de la única ruta que comunica
a esta región con Armenia y con el mundo
exterior desde hace 14 días
Aparentemente un grupo de activistas
azerbainos cortaron el corredor de
lachin que como les decía es la única
vía terrestre que comunica a la región
con el mundo exterior el cierre ha
provocado desabastecimiento de bienes de
medicinas al punto que el gobierno de
Armenia ha acusado azerbaiyán de
provocar una crisis humanitaria entre
tanto es cuestionado también el papel de
Rusia cuyas tropas son garantes de paz y
estabilidad en la región
hemos estado 14 días bajo un bloqueo
total impuesto por azerbaiyán ya que la
única carretera que une en adorno
caravag con el mundo exterior está
cerrada
durante 14 días no se ha permitido la
entrada de alimentos medicinas
combustibles u otros productos vitales
en nagorno caravag
Hablamos ahora del presidente ruso
Vladimir Putin quien se refirió a la
posibilidad de instalar una mesa de
negociaciones con las partes
involucradas en la guerra en Ucrania sin
embargo la invasión al territorio de
este país continúa en bahamut y gersón
allí continúan desarrollándose fuertes
combates Rafael Pérez nos cuenta más
proteger los intereses nacionales y de
su gente Este es el objetivo principal
de la invasión rusa Ucrania a decir del
presidente Vladimir Putin sin embargo el
mandatario ratificó la disposición de
sentarse a la mesa de conversaciones
estamos preparados para negociar
soluciones aceptables con todas las
partes implicadas en el proceso es cosa
suya no somos nosotros los que nos
negamos a negociar son ellos no es la
primera vez que el presidente se refiere
al diálogo en lo que va de semana en
otra ocasión subrayó que todos los
conflictos terminan en la mesa de
negociaciones y que Moscú no renunciaba
a ello sin embargo condicionó a lo que
calificó de soluciones aceptables
sabemos
cambia lo que dice con frecuencia no
está acostumbrado que alguien cuestiona
lo que le está diciendo y en este
momento yo creo que no tenemos una
respuesta Clara cuál pueden ser estos
condiciones
Rusia ha perdido el terreno en Ucrania a
pesar que fue declarada
Rusia declaró estos territorios como
parte de su territorio nuevamente pero
básicamente yo creo que debemos esperar
que van a aparecer mayores detalles por
ahora no está muy claro Cuáles van a ser
estas condiciones en este sentido la
guerra continúa en bahmud objetivo del
kremlin desde hace semanas Los
bombardeos Invasores no cesan
pensé que este sábado se viviría un
ambiente festivo pero de ninguna manera
ya que todos los días estamos lidiando
con el sufrimiento de las personas sabes
y eso tiene sus consecuencias
los enfrentamientos también prosiguen en
allí 13 asentamientos fueron afectados
por los ataques de las fuerzas del
kremlin el conflicto cumplió este 24 de
diciembre 10 meses de acciones
ininterrumpidas sin una posibilidad
visible del cese de los ataques
en otros temas el Ministerio de sanidad
de China Indicó que dejará de publicar
estadísticas oficiales de muertes y
contagios por Kobe 19 esto mientras los
hospitales del país están al borde del
colapso
estás en escenas que no se veían en
China desde 2020 Durante los últimos
días los servicios de emergencias en
Shanghai se han visto saturados los
trabajadores de la salud convierten los
pasillos en salas de tratamiento para
acomodar a tantos pacientes como sea
posible la mayoría son ancianos y
necesitan apoyo respiratorio a dos
semanas del fin de la estricta política
covid cero ahora el país se enfrenta una
ola sin precedentes del virus afuera del
hospital esta mujer no sabe a dónde
llevar a
no me quedan fuerzas su fiebre no baja
las autoridades de Shanghai han
establecido unas 2.600 clínicas de
fiebre para hacer frente al aumento de
casos positivos en este el número de
pacientes se ha multiplicado por 20 en
tan solo unos días
le estoy recetando medicamentos
antiinflamatorios para tratar sus
síntomas
no podemos quedarnos Aquí no hay cama
hay muy pocos médicos en este hospital y
están abrumados las calles de la capital
económica de China vuelven a estar
desiertas y los pocos que se aventuran a
salir apenas pueden reconocer su ciudad
está claro que la epidemia es grave
muchas personas están trabajando desde
casa Mientras que otras están enfermas
las funcionarios de la salud de China
estiman que unos 37 millones de personas
se contagiaron de covid en Solo un día
durante la última semana contribuyendo a
los 248 millones de casos registrados
desde el comienzo de diciembre casi un
quinto de la población china
es todas las noticias buenas noches
[Música]